homelessness has been rising in
America's West Coast cities for more
than a decade entire blocks of Los
Angeles San Francisco and Portland are
occupied by tent encampments plagued by
violence drug overdoses and disease but
the problem is concentrated in a handful
of cities while nationwide at the
homeless population has been shrinking
for a decade to figure out why some
places are so much more successful than
others we took a trip to Texas where the
homeless population declined almost 30
percent over the last decade as it grew
by more than 40 percent in California
today the Lone Star State counts 90
homeless people per 100 000 residents
versus California where the problem is
almost five times as bad not only does
Texas have vastly different politics and
policies from the West Coast but it's
also home to three large cities with
three very different approaches to
homelessness Austin San Antonio and
Houston
from a privately run Village of tiny
homes just outside Austin to a
non-profit serving San Antonio's
homeless with an intensive no excuses
treatment and skills training program to
a single centralized provider in Houston
that streamlined its approach quickly
housing thousands of the city's homeless
residents what we found in Texas was
innovation
but the federal government doesn't fund
for decades it's committed to a
one-size-fits-all approach known as
housing first
States like California have followed
suit leaving many Charities with a
choice to either fall in line or turn
down millions in federal funding and
state grants
the result more people living and dying
on the streets as Governors and Big City
Mayors promise that the much-awaited
free permanent housing is just around
the corner
our first stop was the city of Austin
where Progressive activism exists in the
shadow of a conservative State House
it's a boom in bus town a magnet for
business and Tech Innovation which has
lured some of silicon Valley's top
performers
when the ultra Rich moved in housing
prices started to resemble San
Francisco's and the homeless population
has climbed
policy wise Austin has a lot in common
with West Coast cities which helps
explain the huge encampments here
but Austin has an advantage that San
Francisco and Los Angeles don't when you
walk over the City Line you're in a more
typical Texas municipality where light
touch regulation allows Innovative
approaches to thrive
the outskirts of Austin are home to
Community First Village a 51-acre
community of tiny homes the project
doesn't rely on federal money and
therefore isn't Bound by rules imposed
by Washington
Alan Graham who founded Community First
Village attributes homelessness to the
lack of a supportive network of friends
family and neighbors and seeks to
rebuild that Network by giving formerly
homeless people the opportunity to live
in a community again
the single greatest cost of homelessness
is a profound catastrophic loss of
family
homes are intentionally designed with
large front porches within a walkable
Community to encourage socialization
among neighbors to live here residents
have to respect the law and follow rules
like keeping pets leashed junk off their
driveways and drug use out of the common
areas but behind closed doors that's
their business what we always wanted is
for people to live the way that people
want to live here in the United States
of America we have an extraordinary
number of freedoms we don't want people
coming into our home seeing what we do
in the privacy of our own homes what you
do there is is your biz
and so we tried to create that same
environment but there are three
fundamental rules to live here rule
number one above all rules period end of
story you must pay rent the monthly
costs for one of these houses is between
240 and 440 dollars depending on the
size and amenities which residents
typically pay out of their monthly
Social Security or disability benefits
prior to covid we had a 99 rent
collection oh wow deal on time
and it turns out that people that have
skin in the game
are bought into the game far more than
people that don't have skin in the game
evidence we spoke with agreed
one thing that I've learned since I've
been out here is unconditional love
which I've never had except from my
grandmother who was dead for over 15. oh
it's still conditional oh sometimes with
certain people but not with your mama
I can understand honestly this is the
most incredible place in the world
people might listen I sit down and talk
to them they just want someone to talk
to
um there are a lot of really broken
people here you've got no one to turn to
if you're you know financially broke
bankrupt if you have no family
what'd you do up again the street
and then he taught me that and that's
what we're here every day because when
people realize we're all good people
they're all good people here we love you
all
mobile loves and Fishes Graham's
non-profit launched Community First
village with about a dozen homes in 2015
and has since expanded to more than 300.
the goal is to reach 500 units by the
end of this year to meet the growing
demand while also breaking ground on 127
Acres across the street and inside
Austin an expansion underwritten by 35
million dollars worth of funds from the
federal American Rescue plan act that
will eventually Make Way for 1400 more
homes
Community First Village is located just
outside of Austin City Limits Graham
says it would have been impossible to
build it on the other side of the line
we are blessed with the reality that
there is no zoning no discretionary land
use Authority outside of a municipal
boundary
and that's a big deal because that is
singularly the only tool that NIMBY can
sink their teeth into NIMBY stands for
not in my backyard a term used to
describe activists who Lobby to block
new real estate development within
Austin City Limits developers have to
contend with zoning restrictions and
preservation laws which have made it
hard to meet the huge increase in demand
cause in part by wealthy professionals
fleeing coastal cities residents
thwarted plans to rewrite the zoning
code which would have allowed more
vacant or underutilized properties to be
transformed into multi-family housing
units with nearby retail versus such
strict business and residential
demarcations
a common refrain among urbanists and
disgruntled residents is that Austin is
like San Francisco in the 90s those who
migrated to the city and bought houses
early stand to gain from The Soaring
prices but many others are getting
priced out or pushed farther from the
city center
the City of Austin itself which is
probably where the most demand would be
is hyper NIMBY urbanist Scott buyer has
studied the interaction between zoning
laws housing prices and homelessness he
points out that Austin suburbs have
stayed relatively affordable despite
large population growth
the prices within the city itself are
quite high but then when you get to the
more
I'd say mostly Northern suburbs that are
more liberalized you're getting a lot
lower prices still many austinites don't
appear to see the relationship between
the zoning and land use changes they
oppose and the fact that affordability
is getting worse and worse but land use
restrictions especially zoning shaped
the ability of each City we visited to
respond to its homelessness problem
another crucial aspect was the strings
attached to Government funding as the
operator of a faith-based charity not
reliant on federal funding Graham is
free to experiment including by coming
up with cheaper ways to build his tiny
homes
some tiny homes are 3D printed While
others are prefabricated and still
others are bare bone Shacks that don't
contain any plumbing and require
residents to use shared kitchens and
bathrooms we the people want our
government to be risk-free and as a
result of asking them to be risk-free
it lacks Innovation and if you want to
do something Innovative like this where
you have a home that's got no Plumbing
inside of it in order to be able to lift
people up off the streets the government
can't and doesn't do that because it's
so onerous to build housing for people
in this country that the cost of a of a
HUD approved housing project in in the
state of Texas it's going to be
somewhere between a quarter of a million
and three hundred thousand dollars per
unit
how much does it cost you guys for these
two phases right here on average under
eighty thousand dollars a unit for
everything that you see including this
beautiful building that you're sitting
in right now Federal funding requires
that Homeless service providers conform
to a policy approach called housing
first which focuses on getting clients
into Apartments as quickly as possible
Services can then be offered as an
option but they're not stipulated nor is
Readiness for Independent Living
assessed Graham says this approach is
limiting the federal government through
HUD has latched on to housing first as
the way into the deal it's one way and
it's a way and it's a piece of the
puzzle and it's an important piece of
the puzzle but it can't be the only
piece of that puzzle but Community First
may have its own limitations the
pandemic put extra stress on them as an
eviction moratorium made enforcing basic
rules more difficult and one resident
told us safety concerns have grown along
with the population of the neighborhood
raising questions about whether or not
to hire a security team which would be
costly and could change the entire
nature of the community
and although they are quickly scaling up
Community First only serves a fraction
of Austin's estimated 4 600 homeless
population the city of Austin's lead
homelessness agency accepts HUD money
and is therefore subject to the same
Federal mandates that operators in
California are most concerning for many
austinites is the growing visibility of
the unsheltered homeless population in
2019 before the pandemic the city
council repealed Austin's 23 year old
anti-camping ordinance which led to so
much Street camping that voters
reinstated the ban with a 2021
referendum called prop B
Austin's combination of Street camping
artificially constrained housing Supply
and a network of homeless service
providers hamstrung by federal
guidelines has led to the city beginning
to resemble some of the worst failures
of the West Coast and that brings us to
San Antonio which blazed its own path
for helping the homeless
we weren't so interested in feeding
someone overnight or putting them up
overnight I mean we agreed with it but
that wasn't our goal our goal was to
transform to make them different people
have a different life and be able to
participate in our society
Phil hardberger served as San Antonio's
mayor from 2005 to 2009 a period in
which the city's homeless population
grew by about one thousand but he
reversed this trend by partnering with
the Valero founding CEO Bill grahey to
build a non-profit homeless service
provider called Haven for Hope on a
22-acre land lot owned by the city
to build the campus gree he raised more
than 100 million dollars mostly from the
private sector and contributed lots of
his own fortune as well
today Haven for Hope offers room and
board Healthcare child care and even a
kennel as well as a comprehensive life
skills program including job training
mental health counseling and addiction
treatment
to live here residents have to agree to
learn practical life skills making it to
class attending counseling staying clean
and continuing along the path to
Independence
Stephanie Abel is a mother of six she
and her husband who works as a
dishwasher reside in the family dorms
with their kids at Haven for Hope I'm
actually currently getting my GED which
is one of the many things that they help
with here I think thank you Jesus and I
take parenting classes here the the
parenting classes that I'm taking
provide like diapers wives and clothes
stuff like that which they also provide
here in the family dorm you know going
over like different jobs and stuff that
you can have what what kind of salary is
better based on how big your family is
and stuff a lot of it I didn't know like
yeah I just learned the other day that a
mortician makes like 50 000 and
something I was like yeah exactly
for people unable or unwilling to follow
the program who just need immediate
assistance to get off the streets for a
night or two there's a separate area
called the courtyard which offers
security heat food laundry and a shared
indoor space with beds the same
counseling and treatment services are
offered on this side but they aren't
mandatory
the nonprofit serves about 85 percent of
San Antonio's homeless population
housing about 7 000 people annually
according to internal reports Haven
houses about a thousand clients a year
91 percent have stayed in their new
homes after a year for the majority of
the population we've found that this
Innovative approach of you know working
on the trauma that brought them to
homelessness first in the first place
really makes a difference in their
housing stability long term Kim Jeffries
is Haven for Hope's president and CEO
she says that private funding has given
them the flexibility to offer services
better tailored to the needs of their
clients shelters that rely heavily on
federal funding are subject to more
restrictions because of the
one-size-fits-all housing first mandate
championed by Democratic and Republican
administrations the housing first
movement started in the 1980s and took
off during the George W Bush
Administration I remember the Bush
Administration describing this housing
first model as part of their approach to
passionate conservatism you may remember
that phrase coming out of that era
because far too many Americans go
homeless On Any Given night this bill
provides comprehensive new resources for
homeless Americans Obama banded it with
the Hearth Act of 2009 which made
focusing on rapid re-housing a
requirement for those receiving federal
funds
the result was predictable Federal money
was spent on pricier permanent
Supportive Housing and the use of
temporary Emergency Shelters decreased
facing a critical lack of beds shelters
started turning people away
in 2018 the ninth Circuit Court of
Appeals upheld a ruling that enforcement
of anti-camping laws in cities lacking
emergency beds was cruel and unusual
punishment and thus unconstitutional
with major cities lacking adequate beds
and therefore the legal right to
prohibit Street camping entire
neighborhoods of Los Angeles and San
Francisco turned to squalor
San Antonio doesn't allow Street camping
though like in any large city it's
possible to find encampments nestled
beneath Highway overpasses the community
has said we're not going to allow
encampments and you know our city does
encampment sweeps and we know about them
in advance so we can go out and do
Outreach and talk to them and say hey
they're going to come be coming in two
days we know exactly when they're coming
and so they don't allow it so I think it
is helpful in our success and getting
people off the streets we ideally should
have a hundred different models for
homeless provision because homelessness
is a complex situation and there's a lot
of different types of people who are
homeless in a recent policy report he
co-authored for California's independent
Institute buyer analyzed some of the
problems with housing first
the intentions were good but I think
also
the outcomes
could have been quite predictable in a
sense if you're funding people to
basically live on the street in the
state of disrepair in a state of in
sobriety and drug use and you say that
even despite living like this you're
going to get free housing it seems like
you would encourage a lot more of that
behavior buyer argues that mandating
housing first has crippled policy
innovation in major West Coast cities it
seems like in the age of effective
altruism if you have wealthy people who
want to really discover like a hack for
ending homelessness and getting people
back into stable lives it seems like
there would in fact be quite a lot of
experimentation and homeless provision
around the United States I think a lot
of that Innovation is getting squelched
when we have a federal government that
only allocates grants based on this one
very specific model that we call housing
first
about 15 of the the individuals that we
serve on an annual basis we serve about
7 000 people the housing first model
works for the other 85 percent they need
different kinds of stability before they
move into that model most communities
they're funding for homelessness comes
from HUD and so when HUD made that shift
to housing first it took it away from
emergency shelter and so San Antonio
invested heavily in emergency shelter at
that time at the same time but other
communities the approach followed the
fundings and so we can have different
interventions for different people
because we're not totally reliant on the
federal government to fund it three
years after La voters passed a 1.2
billion dollar Bond measure to help the
city's homeless population the city had
completed just one percent of the
promised ten thousand units and the
average cost of building each apartment
was about half a million dollars at the
high end the cost exceeded eight hundred
thousand dollars
Union Rescue Mission one of the city's
largest and oldest homeless service
providers didn't get any of that funding
because it didn't conform to the housing
first approach mandated by the state of
California
Union Rescue Mission CEO Andy Bales told
reason that City officials laughed at
him for suggesting a different approach
some of my counterparts who depend on
measure H and measure HH money they're
afraid to speak the truth they can't
speak the truth otherwise they would get
in great difficulty and be defunded
right and so it gives me some measure of
comfort to to be able to speak up what I
believe but I think pride and arrogance
is really holding us back from doing
some of the the needed things we need to
do to immediately solve this issue
the winds have changed in late 2021 an
LA County Supervisor appointed Bales to
help oversee the County's response to
homelessness don't be afraid of the
dogmatic housing first permanent you
know permanent sport of housing people
don't be afraid of the NIMBY
but there's one city in Texas where
housing first is actually working well
[Music]
as the New York Times reported last year
Houston has reduced its homeless count
by more than 60 percent over the past
decade while placing more than 25 000
people in permanent units so how did
America's fourth largest city succeed by
going all in on housing first while Los
Angeles San Francisco and Portland have
failed so miserably it really is about
permanent housing with Supportive
Services as the only solution in
homelessness
Anna Roush is the vice president of
program operations at the Coalition for
the homeless of Houston and Harris
County the Metro's sole coordinating
agency
while many cities have several
organizations in this role Houston
relies on a single non-profit and it's
the first stop for any homeless person
entering the system
Roush says that this makes it easier to
efficiently route clients where they
need to go and to track outcomes
he says that the housing Readiness
approach in San Antonio which has a
Metro region population about one-third
the size of Houston's wouldn't scale
who determines if somebody's housing
ready to me it's like that's that's a
that's a basic need right every human
needs housing and food and clothing How
can any organization determine if
someone is housing ready I don't think
that's for us to decide I would just ask
you to look at the cost of that so
you're you're paying to House people in
a courtyard so you're basically paying
to leave people unsheltered in a
courtyard or homeless in a courtyard and
then compare the exact same
vulnerability people to be served in
permanent housing and see which costs
more I've been doing this for 23 years
and housing the housing first approach
works several Studies have shown that
housing first does better at keeping
chronically homeless people with serious
mental illness off the street then more
intensive housing Readiness
interventions but other research has
casted doubt on its Effectiveness its
impact on health outcomes and whether
its results hold up over time there's a
sizable minority of homeless people
who literally are just mentally ill who
cannot help themselves you know they
need I think society's help and through
a combination of maybe government and
philanthropic funding maybe that would
be an appropriate demographic to use the
housing first model for but we don't
really know because right now the
federal government is pursuing this
one-size-fits-all model
besides limiting innovation in homeless
Services governments also make housing
artificially expensive Roush says that
the reason housing first works so well
in Houston but not in Los Angeles has
everything to do with the cost of
building they put all this money towards
homelessness but that they've only been
able to spend a fraction of it because
they can't build it anything there are
people that complain the loudest about
homelessness but then they're the ones
that are lobbying not to have affordable
housing built in their backyard so you
can't have your cake and eat it too and
that's what's happening in La that is
exactly what's happening in La there
need more affordable housing they need
more physical units built but they can't
do it because they're literally in their
own way of building affordable housing
in La Houston is famous for not having
zoning townhouses run up against
multi-family apartment buildings sitting
atop ground level businesses a
crematorium neighbors high-end
Condominiums skyscrapers Loom over
single-family neighborhoods in a city
where you just don't have to ask much
permission to build we really have never
cultivated this sort of NIMBY mechanism
in Houston and it's really never become
part of the culture for the most part
Tory Gaddis an urbanist who specializes
in Houston land regulation says that the
result of the city's laissez-faire
approach is that despite massive
population growth over the past decade
housing prices are stable that's because
it's difficult for interest groups to
stop a development project people don't
even think much about like oh an
apartment complex is going up down the
street or a tower is going in over there
they don't even think to fight it at the
city level because there's not really a
lot of mechanism for them to fight that
whereas I think a lot of these cities
have built in this culture of like if
anything gets built you have mechanisms
to stop it Houston also has no Urban
growth boundaries unlike its West Coast
counterparts meaning that in addition to
Growing upward housing can easily spread
outward to accommodate both affordable
City and Suburban living without zoning
or excessive environmental review laws
neighborhood groups can't easily block
new housing projects on adjacent land
but master planned communities and
long-standing neighborhoods can create
and enforce private deed restrictions to
prevent homeowners from suddenly turning
a single-family house into a four-story
building without Community input
so for a city that's already entrenched
and has already chosen to go the zoning
route a city like La maybe what should
they do like how would they move in
Houston's Direction given that they're
not starting from scratch they don't
have a blank slate and and it's
obviously not probably realistic for
them to wipe out zoning entirely as as
wonderful as that would be you know I
emphasize that yes protect your
single-family neighborhoods that's where
your biggest political opposition is
going to be and that's what Houston has
allowed with the deed restrictions but
then let all the rest of your land open
up whether it's commercial or industrial
Let It Go multi-family if that's what
the market needs Let It Go mixed use
that should not generate near as much
opposition as the single-family
neighborhoods as long as they're
protected the rest of your land really
should be fairly flexible
a big reason Texas has a lower homeless
population than California traces back
to zoning and construction costs housing
first Works in Houston because it's so
cheap to build Austin is expensive like
a coastal city but the unincorporated
swath of Travis County outside of City
Limits provided Alan Graham with a spot
for his tiny home community
what's also working in Texas is a
willingness to give local social
entrepreneurs the flexibility to craft
policies that best serve their homeless
populations instead of forcing them to
adhere to one-size-fits-all Federal
policies the whole regime of government
funding of homelessness
I think drives out a lot of private
philanthropy
um because
when people particularly in the US see
homeless people panhand laid on the side
of the road I think a lot of their gut
reaction is like well that person
actually could get help because there's
all kinds of government funding for them
I think there would be a lot of
Market appetite for solving homelessness
from the philanthropic sector that
does not happen because people just
assume the government is supposed to do
it we believe that government should
play a subsidiary role to We the People
in mitigating these profound human
issues that are out there like
homelessness but we've abdicated this to
the government as a society and we're
we're reaping what we're sowing
[Music]